[Music]
okay welcome to my first time teaching
this class end games exclam warmer
muscle okay so we're going to look at
four end games I played before you were
born and when I say you I mean Bensimon
and possibly you at home and these were
all different kinds of end games except
that I won them hooray
if I ever show a game I lost then it's
time to take me away the first game
strangely enough is against Robert James
Fisher his middle name actually is James
I don't know if he was named after him
but he's an expert master who's lived I
think most of his life in Indiana and
doesn't have anything with the other one
except he can make legal moves but
otherwise I guess the other one can't
now anyway
this was played 86 and actually this is
good for any game class because I want a
prize for this game best end game okay
the guy who gave me the prizes my friend
but I'm not the one on trial here it was
$50 I remember in 86 I thought that was
a lot of money now I'll give you $50 to
not teach the class each one of you we
agree I'll give you 40 okay and you at
home no wait when other guys did is the
camera was like right here yeah the
camera was you know I was like okay so
you were taught by some crazy teacher
somewhere that when it's opposite color
bishop's that means it's a draw okay but
I'm here to tell you the truth it's
never a draw and when it's rooking
opposite color bishop's it's always a
win okay even if you agree to withdraw
I'm not as the director I'm not going to
it's going to be a win okay and here
black has many advantages you don't just
look at the bishop's ago okay it's a
draw
obviously my rook is better his works of
the corner
okay he's falling REM fan okay nothing
yeah
and one guy pretends he got it he's from
Canada he'll get it like in an hour okay
so his rips in the corner and I'm in the
spotlight that's me in the spotlight all
right now a couple more you got it
and also my
pretty activist threatening stuff but
more important than that because of his
stupid pawn structure on the kingside
that's not the plumb structure you want
when your opponent has a white squared
bishop and you don't so I'm going to
take advantage of that and take
advantage of my better look and I'll
have good winning chances also I'm
slightly higher rated which much offense
related okay
he played rook c1 because unlike most of
you at home he saw his bishop was
attacked nice if his bishop moves away
obviously I take the b3 pawn if I want
okay now you guys remember what I said
so you know what move I made here this
should be seven yeah because that's
that's not good
okay and I told my private students but
I'm not going to tell you so don't
listen turn your volume down when you
have that fun structure on the Kings
side you have to have a bishop on g2
then you're okay now you have no white
square control so where's my bishop
going next to move the f3 and then you
can't really move too much
okay so King f1 threatened and king e 2
and king e 2 is now illegal so yeah now
he's much worse and he played h4 putting
it in H and I played out six and this is
something most people sort of this
understand this is actually very easy
because when you have obviously colored
bishops or you don't you almost always
want to put your pawns on the opposite
color of your Bishop that way your
Bishop can move everywhere a lot of
weaker players put on the same color of
their Bishop because they think the
bishop could defend their funds then
which is true but then your bishop can't
move it's good to move that's why I
always sit seven a chair so I can't move
wait so I have all my pawns on the color
that I want them green and my opponent
was very envious
so his pawns are on red you'll get that
later when you get home and since my
funds are on dark squares my bishop
could move everywhere and more
importantly his bishop can't move
anywhere okay I'm trying to restrict his
Bishop he's not doing a good job
restricting my bishop he's making it so
my dish
anywhere okay so my king to move up the
board and I always give the same lecture
ten games I showed the game between
Irina's ENIAC and Sabina boys or from
the 2009 US women I'm sure you all
memorize that game it stop laughing at
home they did and that game we saw a
look at night end game where White was a
pawn up and had very good winning
chances and over the next 13 moves black
moved your king of the board and white
left your king on h1
I wonder who won that game oh not the
person who left their King on h1 so
black one and I show that endgame a lot
and I always told my students one of
them would be my wife move your king up
the board the endgame and then like
everything else in life they don't
listen to me okay not that my wife never
listens to me although she doesn't so
I'm always like move your king I move
your king up and they're like no okay so
when I play f6 not only my restricting
the bishop and putting the pawn in the
right color now my king can move up the
board I'm a grandmaster so I could move
there in one move might take you guys
longer okay my opponent played King g1
showing why his king f1 was brilliant
now he just didn't know what to do
because my real condition for dominating
this is the d5 attacking his pawn now
this may surprise you at home and in the
in the room and it might even surprise
Orlando who doesn't know whether to push
or pull okay but at the end game
especially this kind of endgame but in
most kinds there's one way to win what's
the most common way you would win an
endgame I'll give you a hint
I'll give you him you could understand
that they're not going to understand it
in the first three rounds of Norway
which is ongoing and for you at home and
end of the week ago that right yeah so
the first three rounds of Norway there
were 13 draws and two wins
okay fighting tournament and of the two
wins
I'm sure you've both been you've all
memorized those games there was a game
anon Kramnik where kram nicola with
black and i came over the other game
because i can't remember anything
Nakamura B Giri I do remember is lucky
both games were won for the same reason
they're both one of the
gengan what was that reason it's the
same as this one you can guess how do
you win an endgame you have a mating
attack by sacking four pieces now
Somebody Anybody when would you say any
you might be right
I can't do that he won't let me am I
playing your opponents I playing this
guy is Robert James Fisher come on man
anybody else taking your opponents
plunge is good but why's that could you
make a queen that's all you had to say
okay and when Kramnik was playing anon
and kramnik won and when nakamura play
giri and Nakamura won
they both had passed a pawns it must
have learned for Nia and they push their
pawns really far and their opponents
resigned they would have queen but their
pawn didn't want to see that okay that
tell you what an endgame as you make a
queen if you don't make a queen it's
hard to win that's why when you're
defending an endgame and you're worse
you try to trade all the pawns then if
your phone doesn't make a queen what are
they going to do like B jump well maybe
not him okay
so forgive the info rook and Bishop
versus rook in theory as a draw and
you're up a hole bishop so if somehow
you could trade all the pawns up and
give a dish above you to be drawing in
theory not in practice okay so I play
Bishop d5 because I want to play Bishop
takes b3 he played the obvious move
there's only one obvious move yeah he
has to save his pawn so you played
before and now when I play a floor my
plums closer to queening I like cleaning
okay I saw those games even though they
were played thirty years later okay so
now this pawn is very close to queening
if only I could get rid of this pawn
I'll do anything to get rid of that pawn
you don't want to know what I'll do to
get rid of that pawn
although I was 1986 I Plus shouldn't say
that okay so I played a for my opponents
like you're not doing nothing he played
b5 and he's keeping my pawn on here and
he's blocking all the pawns up so I
can't do anything
that was very mean of him he gave
himself to be Foursquare for his bishop
otherwise his bishop could move anywhere
okay I played h5 this is called fixing
I'm fixing his pawns all in the dumb
color
where I can meet him eventually if his
rook ever gets active somewhere then he
has to watch out for checkmate but if he
can move his pawns on the Kings side he
doesn't have to watch out so h5 fixing
his pawns on a bad color should be for
king of seven king f1 this guy's a
genius King f1 King G one King f1 that's
why he'd be twenty grand masters boy
that was the other guy I never liked
this ship f3 again always repeat king g1
there could be three th - King e6 with
c3 okay so now I treated rooks and we
drew now and if I trade rooks which is
not good and then I went upon by force
if I can't maybe I care maybe King g5
does okay but we're going to cheat
because I like that okay I'm just going
to take this pawn I'm not even going to
try yeah now you can see it's not easy
for black to win because it's impossible
good reason I have an extra pawn it's
useless I can't get up I can't do
anything okay so instead of trading
works and drawing instead of moving my
rook away and losing my bishop I just
ignored his move I played King g5 okay
the problem is if he takes my rook with
the drawn opposite color dish' pending
this pawn is even closer to queening
okay eventually the Indigo Girls wrote a
song about this closer to fine gold when
we get the name of the song they never
heard it Indigo Girls hello okay which
is actually okay in my book
alright and then this pawn is going to
clean and when you stop it from queening
my King comes and helps so he can he can
take my rook so he did Robert James
Fisher clock blade rookie three and now
I took his rook right then I trick you
you're from candidate I trick you will
let the Cuban now okay somebody beat him
up yeah all right all right so Ricky
three now I made it him with rook here
and rook here why didn't I do that
anybody a doctor in here because it's an
x-ray
my rook is defending my bishop through
his rock so if I play her beat when he
takes my bishop it looks good but not
too good
okay so I played this should be four and
that has a threat
it looks like I'm trying to meet him and
I'm trying to you know well I'm trying
to save my bishop because he keeps
attacking it but I actually have an idea
you played King age three okay
that way his king is as far as possible
from the plunge I want to clean like
that's that good yeah so that was a bad
move and now what did I do
I do you remember what I did I did
something anybody have a guess I'm with
my king up I got my bishop up I got my
rook up which I could clean I would
never do that
Bishop f5 check then I sacrifice the
exchange right the reason is and your
move also wins but I want to play King
c4 but if my bishop sent me four I
probably shouldn't do that yeah so but
it's still win two just would be so then
I sacrificed the exchange because I want
to make a queen okay that's more
important than to work for a bishop and
I finally got my past pawn yeah and as
we say at the top level that pawn is
going to cost him a rook because that
ponds gonna cost him a rook but he
showed me he made a lot of King moves
doing nothing that was good right now
again I tell my students every game I
have examples move your king up in the
endgame
what would Gregory Kai jonov would say
he would say how come you guys haven't
heard of me that's the first thing he
would say the second thing I think he
was specially sent to you the second
thing he would say is I'm up a king
because he said that to be one I was
playing him and I was down two pawns an
endgame and I drew and he's like what
you're up the King of course it's a draw
even though I was down two pawns and
here I would Sam up a king I have a
you don't my Kings doing something your
king's hanging around okay so my king is
winning all of your pawns and it's
helping my pawn become a queen if my
king was on h7 I'd probably take white
because it looks better than addition
okay but my Kings are C form up a king I
have two pieces you have one
okay he played rookie seven now I'm
really surprised
I played the next move because as a
young player in 86 I would want to make
a queen but I guess I was good because I
wasn't in a hurry usually weak players
in a hurry and stronger players like I
would have rolling later
so g6 no pawn for you okay if you want
to take my F pawn and let me queen for
nothing okay MEP plays like rook up
seven that's a good move
and then rook have six whoa and then
here I'll count I'll take my F pawn and
for those of you who think you can win
my you can prevent me from cleaning sink
again a.m. okay so he's not going to win
my F pawn he can't win my beep line
because if he attacks it I could play
King dings d5 so I'm just going to make
a queen but he can't have any of my
Kings side plunge because it's possible
of the very unlikely he could sacrifice
his rook for my a pawn and if he has
more pawns on the Kings side that could
be dangerous but I doubt it but here I
just wanted him do it okay he made King
f1 his kings gonna beat my a pawn right
now and the truth hurts okay and what's
blacks next we're going to be the blacks
next move yeah what's what's it yeah
King b2 and yeah okay so that was very
easy so I won by sacrificing the
exchange of getting a passed pawn but
before I got the passed pawn I had to
force his pawn to b4 so I could play a
four and get a little closer and
actually hooked in a lot of openings and
middle games when I'm randomly pushing a
five a four to soften them up I think
about am I going to clean that pawn in
20 moves and the answers now but if it
was yes I'd be pretty
so in the endgame what are the most
important things well two of them which
happened here which is why I'm lecturing
is Kings King position moving your king
up which I did in my opponent didn't do
and getting past pawn those are very
important those are more important than
other things you do like winning in
exchange or having a better pawn
structure if you can make a queen
I recommend it if your King moves up as
Gregory kind of likes to say you up a
king alright so I actually won $50
because of that and I still have it
they believe me too all right this is
one of my favorite games because number
one my opponent was German that's the
first thing number two I was playing in
the Netherlands and the Dutch just loved
the Germans like we all do and it was
the last round and I was having a bad
tournament as usual and my opponent
having a great tournament okay so he was
getting paired off and and he needed a
draw for his I am norm and if I win lose
or draw it doesn't matter I'm getting
crushed every game okay so we play in
the last round and I have a reputation
that I've earned although this might
have been one of the starting games of
it I don't give anybody anything for a
norm so if I playing Carlson and I'm
black it needs a draw for a GM norm he's
not getting it he's gonna win instead
but he's not going to get it I don't get
anybody in norm ever okay if you're
higher rated than me if you need to draw
than too bad okay so in the last round
I've been beaten and drawn for norms but
I don't give you a norm
I don't play ten wasn't agree to a draw
and this was one such case I moved ten
he offered me a draw it was a very
boring rady and wasn't interesting okay
but in my opinion I'm not only helping
myself because I want to play chess I'm
helping my opponent because I don't want
him to go through the rest of his life
and think what I have drawn or won that
game if he didn't give me a draw okay he
didn't offer enough money either the
deutsche mark was weak anyway so this
way if he does win or draw he knows he
earned it okay nice theories about
myself where I could have played a quick
draw in the last round I got in the GM
but I wanted to earn my norm so I lost
19 because I drew yeah I did lose one
too
okay so this is the starting position of
our end game black has a few advantages
okay and usually when you see this pawn
structure you see a pawn on c4 for white
and upon on c64 black it's advantageous
to both sides depending on if they can
do what they want to do here I can do
what I want to do what he can
so if Kevin cages to me the advantage
for black is obvious I can go to d4 with
my pieces he cannot go to d5 with his
pieces we can but I'll take it
okay so that's always the case when you
see this fun structure however the
advantage for white if he can achieve it
is pushing all his Queen side bonds of
making a clean and gaining space so if
he could play d4 and c5 and stick a
knight on d6 then white has a good
position but I obviously can't do any of
that you can play b4 can't play c5 can't
play Knight d6 but in the middle game
that would actually be a good planner
for Wyatt but since no those moves are
legal lose all your pawns this is just
good for black right now
a mild advantage I have is this pawns
defended a lot and that puns not so
sometimes I can get a tempo also if you
want to put the white knight on a good
square I don't know what square that
would be but I know the black guy can go
here and that's why I played Knight f8
earlier and if I change my mind I could
play Knight c5 and attack these two
pawns so I have good squares for my
knight and he doesn't because he can't
play 95 and he can't play Knight c4
those would be good squares for his
Knight I could play 94 and I could play
95 okay it's my move because he just
took on a1 so I played 96 for obvious
reasons he played Queen B - I think he
wants to play b4 like I said and I
played 9 g5 tricking him now I'm
threatening the e4 pawn if I play 95 I'm
sort of locking my queen so for example
if he plays Queen e2 or Queen c2 or
queen b1 and defends his pawn I can take
on a3 so it's not easy to defend your
fun stops begin I am norm so he played
out three breaking my most important
rule you guys new here never play three
you guys at home no they don't yeah okay
now I'm exposing his king will you move
all the plums in front of your king your
king has no cover normally in an end
game you get punished because people put
Queens and rooks up to seventh rank and
checkmate you so you don't want to push
all the pawns in front of your King
because your seventh rank is open here I
don't have a rook but I'll get in anyway
okay Queen g5 check and now he's in
check if he plays queen f2 I could take
on a three or I could play Knight age
three check winning as Queen depending
on whether I see it or not 1992 I want
to see in it now I don't know what do
you think at home what you're thinking
are bees got that okay so he can't play
Queen f2 the reason I play Queen c5 I
want to infiltrate rar so he was just
kidding us then I went rawr
and he called the arbiter over and said
my opponents going rawr neverold is like
a he's been Feingold what do you want
okay now I'm threatening Queen takes
Knight so he probably doesn't want to do
let me do that he can't move his right
anywhere here and if he moves his Knight
to see to that he's hanging his F free
pawn if he moves his Queen and defends
his Knight I can probably take on b3 so
the truth hurts right so what did he do
the answer is I don't know I remember
what he did was 1992 give me a blink
queen f2 all right that's a move looks
like I could take on b3 I hope I did
okay so I want to pawn I don't see what
he can do about it I don't see any
defense to take em b3 I'm threatening
these two pawns but that would give away
this pawn luckily I defended it with my
clean okay he played Queen d2 why did he
do that what's his next move
yeah he wants to come in and also
infiltrate and normally if you can start
checking you have really good chances
for perpetual in six
I have no chances for perpetual and
truth hurts queen bee three trading
Queens now you were all taught not by me
by somebody know that when you're having
material you should trade okay and
that's why you guys have never beaten me
okay
you should trade bad pieces for good
pieces and Queens have a special rule
that I made up I can't tell you because
it's special I'll tell you anyway
I'll tell you at home but not them they
won't listen okay you trade Queens
depending on who's King is safer Queens
are good for checkmating your opponent
very useful if your opponent's king is
exposed it's good to have a queen if
your King is the safest King ever you
don't care if your phone has a queen
whose King is safer black sting is safer
because my my King has this nice
beautiful square on h7 his King is
exposed on the whole rank so I can check
his King and will so my queen is better
than his Queen and his queens like
walking is an ie and I'm attacking his
King so I'm not going to trade Queens
however if I was a betting man I would
bet if I traded Queens I'm still winning
but I think I'm more winning by not
trading Queens so I didn't
we've been funny if I did it was 25
years ago I took Lee I forgot no I know
I did okay so I put him in check and he
played King f1 I was play King f1 and I
took his button I'm two pawns up yes
okay now you might think why did he do
that why didn't he play King to g1 and
defend his age pawn well then I check
and if he goes here I have made with
advantage and after King h1 let's see
how smart the audience is what's that
Knight have to check wins
I wonder if Queen up two wins more when
you see a good look for a better one I
mean I probably would have played that
and not care enough it I wonder if this
threatening Queen Ji Won late is better
anyway it's not good for light okay so
he didn't do that he played King f1
and I took now I'm to plunge ahead okay
he checked I went to safety and he took
my pawn on d6 now I'm one point ahead
and I played night h3 at nine th three
doesn't have an immediate threat because
he's defending but it stops his queen
for taking either one of my pawns
so I'm preventing his queen from doing
anything because his queen has to stop
queen has to mate and I'm still
threatening g3 you could see who's King
is safe for now in case you didn't know
before now you know G for stopping Queen
takes you three Knight f4 with obvious
threats and I remember one of my
students I think it was today was it
today was it yesterday one of them I was
explaining that this is a very bad pawn
structure because you can put something
on f4 and it stays there forever man a
knight on f4 that's pretty good I
couldn't think of a better piece that's
the best piece I would want enough for
here's the knight better than a queen
okay now I'm threatening everything I
wish I was threatening more but paulien
and he played queen f2 stopping my
threats again most of you would trade
Queens because you're up upon obviously
my cleans better than his check kg1
h5 okay get rid of the defense of his
King he has to take because he can't
lose upon and I play Queen e6 so I'm
threatening this pawn I'm threatening
this part 39 h3 check that's a lot of
pressure isn't it okay that's why I
played h5 so my queen could get it sort
of everywhere Knight age three checks
probably more important than the other
threats remember I was telling you that
my Queens better than his and I have my
pom-poms out and everything not like yes
Queen
actually I didn't say it but it was my
night but much better than his old game
his night hasn't moved as it terrible my
nights I'm like the best square ever
okay he played queen c5 preventing night
h3 winning and preventing Queen takes e4
and I play Queen d7 because I want to
play Queen d2 or queen d1 you play King
f1 defending his Knight
and I checked him King f1x collusive
material but I can see why he didn't
want me to come in here because then he
would lose in the ELA okay check and
let's see who the tactical genius of the
audience's could be been assignment
first time you ever called that right
yeah how does black wait immediately
I can't made him but I can take all of
his pieces and if you're taking notes
take all of your opponent's pieces well
though actually my lesson today was one
of my students I told not to do that
true story he said he still made all of
his opponents
I said don't take everything just leave
one thing one I never realized that the
when I started this game from some
position his knight never moved yeah
that's not good yeah there's an audience
agrees with you yeah yeah so I checked
he defended his Knight and I took it
truth hurts yeah yeah and then he
resigned rather than play this ending
where I'm I'm pretty confident here
because positional my pawns I'm seasick
okay so he resigned after Queen takes
Knight so in that game my king was safer
my Queen was better than his Queen my
knight was better than his Knight and he
got no counter play whenever he tried to
check me I played age six and King age
seven tucked my king away and his King
was open forever
he moved his H pawn is G pawn is F
finally pawn so his king was a little
suspicious and you might think it's an
endgame the king is fine well unless I'm
eight you and you all like Queens the
Knights better than Queens and bishops
even though I don't so there you go
that's for you guys and no norm for him
the Germans bought me beer and I'm not
even kidding I'm like kidding a little
I'm not okay and this guy was named Wynn
and he lost and chess is hard maybe some
Canada okay so this is from an exchange
Kings Indian where my opponent played an
inferior line and gave me the two
bishops okay and I never liked the two
bishops until I got the Grandmaster
title and
am to bishops we go okay and here white
has two advantages one we've talked
about when we haven't okay white has the
two bishops advantage okay because I
have two bishops and he doesn't and when
you have two bishops as I've said in
many lectures before one of your bishops
is the same color
we both have a LightSquared bishop and
my bishop has no counterpart
that's the bishop that's going to annoy
him okay and I know about annoying I've
been married three times okay audience
as well yeah okay so the truth hurts now
I have another advantage and that is my
King is doing something and his King is
at home where he doesn't do anything so
my king can walk up the board and I have
a third advantage which we talked about
last game and last game was a
disadvantage
now it's an advantage yay which I didn't
realize that what a smart teacher my
partner done see for his funds on c6 and
the last game that was good for the pawn
on c6 I could play 94 he couldn't play
95 here my pawn on c4 actually stops 95
and I controlled these four and I don't
have to play Knight g5 without have a
knight so care about that but what I do
care about is pushing all of my pawns of
making a queen and if I'm going to push
my Queen side pawns and make a queen
I like this pawn structure because my
pawns on c4 so I can start pushing all
of my pawns and making a queen you might
not believe me but I did it so you can
believe me
alright first of all when I'm playing
chefs I stop my opponents counter play
so what's the scariest slew of black can
play here it's not too scary but it is
the scariest I guess you guys don't
scare easy
again I'm not scared nothing what's the
most aggressive move black can play Rick
d3 check is aggressive it hangs the rook
why don't you didn't mean that you met
Knight a four-track okay now I would
like to kick your night off of Ace of b6
but C 5 gives away the d5 square that
they would take my title away if I
played c5 CD would come and say like
okay years you're like 2100 now okay
even 2100 wouldn't play c5 okay so I
want to play a
five okay kick his night out so the
first move I played was be through now
he can't play night a for my c4 pawn is
protected again and I can play a4 a5 and
if you try to stop me by playing a five
I might take your knight
I might not but I probably would okay so
b3 is the first move
he played f6 breaking my rule never play
of six a4 as advertised night c8 because
I'm going to play five anyway and I did
so I have more space in that pawn
structure which was bad for like the
previous game is now good for white I'm
getting spaced and he's stopping moves
that I want to play I don't buy Knight
d5 I have a knight a six if he never
plays a six that his Knight can't really
do a lot of stuff because his pawns
hanging so he's like okay a six and my
knight could do whatever I want
it's all blocked up I'm gonna draw and I
was like quiet we're playing King before
I told you to activate your King but you
didn't believe me but I'm going to do it
anyway King of seven rip d1 now if I
want to move my king up the board I
think I should get rid of his rook
because I might get made it or not be
able to legally get through so we did
this [ __ ] before I saw my pawn was
attacked H for gaining space G for
gaining more space King c5 as advertised
and now I don't want to see I have a
king and he doesn't but my Kings better
than his and my king is stopping his
knight from moving okay and also his
Bishop can't really move too many places
and I have more space on both sides of
the board so if a grandmaster was into
the in the room here they would be like
oh boy better King more space on both
sides two bishops and I would be like
get a Kleenex and start stop salivating
okay if you're a low rated player
kneeling at 3 against 3 3 against 3
equal draw okay
the stronger you are at chess the more
you like White's position okay so like
Magnus Carlsen vitomir Kramnik this is
what they dream about I don't know you
guys dream about this is what they dream
about okay and if they were in the room
now they would be like well if I was
black I'd resign but White has every
advantage you could have two bishops
better King more space on both sides of
the board and then I got ca can't move
the ship on b1 can't really move too
much either and then kramnik would say
something like you have the dark squares
and I'm like what okay okay so Bishop d3
to move is Bishop and I attacked it you
shut that for Bishop see - yes Bishop's
not the best b4 b5 the problem with its
position is if pawns get traded it's
very difficult to defend b7 so if my
King gets there or my bishop gets there
I'm going to clean my a pawn now I like
cleaning my a pawn
yeah I like that
okay so takes takes and Bishop b4 I
don't care about this pawn I care about
this point okay it's very difficult to
defend this pawn here and once that pawn
is gone my King and bishops and a pawn
are going to win the game now again as I
said in the West and the first position
we did the fewer pawns that are on the
board the more likely it's a draw
unfortunately for him I have two bishops
I know how to mate with two bishops if I
had two knights and he got all my pawns
off the board by stacking all of his
pieces I would have two knights and I
wouldn't win okay as in the game its
Karpov coursethe was 78 or 80 one I
think it was 78 there's a world
championship match where Corey was much
worse but he drew by giving all of his
pieces away and Karpov had two knights
he's like was my dishes I could meet you
addition so the problem with him is if
he gives up all of his pieces for my
past pawns
I can still win okay and also if he
takes my H pawn I'm going to call the
arbiter and be like how did he do that
so my H pawns pretty safe I'm not
worried about losing that okay nine
eight seven I took clay
[ __ ] 855 check you guys would trade
because you always trade I never trade
this should be 8 that's a nice night
that he has a 6 and I take his beep on
because he has counterplay a 7 what do
you play you guys can do it you didn't
we find Mike night takes a 7 I can win
96 there you go
ok luckily there's two sides of the
board so yeah and my king can go either
way whichever way your King goes I'll go
the other way too bad for him yeah and
this was pretty easy Bishop e3 is a
funny move of the traps at night Fischer
style BAM this Knights not too good now
yeah and now the winning plan which
everything wins but this is the funniest
winning plan you guys deserve humor
right that's why I played Bishop e3 so
you can't play by afford and okay
obviously this is a good winning plan to
what's on its money even less funny is
this that's not funny at all and
normally the lower edge you are you like
nice words and bishops that is you
improve your games you like bishops more
you guys pulling out there yet and when
you see like this you're like oh yeah I
guess bishops are better and bishops
aren't always better but when they are
better and you see it you're like man
like to feel good okay bishops can
dominate Knights like that and a lot of
end games especially if you know
Fisher's game's not the Fisher that I
played the real one yeah and this sure
has a lot of famous endings whereas this
sure beats denying it well then I can't
move okay so Bishop III I was a good
player then now I would just sit there
my 5-wood fall but this should be three
yeah and now he's super resigned I got
two points that's a new rule you could
just I super resign I can't leave up
that my game ends and I get to yes yeah
exactly
okay and also he changed his name after
this game because you know for obvious
reasons okay and last but not least
this is the most boring game I've ever
played ever that I ever will play it's
against Ryan Porter like I think quit
chess
if he didn't he should have this is in
the US Open in Chicago right tied for
first
well those in Rosemont but I don't want
to hear the details and I had seven wins
and five draws the US Open used to be 12
rounds
I'm I'm used to police and I was the
strong I am and he was a high expert low
master okay and we got the most boring
position ever this one and this is from
one opening I thought this kind of
position a lot because from the same
opening anybody who yes you know what
kind of Sicilian yes what kind of
dragons be quickly very good okay really
strange for Canadian something okay so
it's not a way to Dragon and recently I
played Bishop d4 check because his King
is good on h1 except it's not good okay
and he plays Rick see one did I give him
the C file now am I gonna play Trixie
seven what am i you and did I trade is
that what I do so I didn't give him the
seed file and I didn't trade so what did
I do
I don't use like no okay I did what John
none calls a collinear move BAM hard for
humans to see he said wow you guys are
proving you're human good job
what's that well you're two-thirds
correct Rick's in five yeah Bishop c5 is
not collinear that's just retreating
okay the rook c5 now my goal here is to
make the position asymmetrical because
if it's a draw then hope you like I drew
a better player and I'm like no so if
it's really really really boring and
there's nothing going on it'll probably
be a draw but if the position is
asymmetrical we can both make mistakes
the big advantage black has here the
computer doesn't think black has a big
advantage but when humans play it's much
better to be black here is my King
potentially could move up the board as
you will see and his King that not as
good okay and if my kin gets up the
boards of d4 d3 I win okay and
he plays a move he didn't play a move oh
you did I can't do it I'm not smart
enough
okay bye dish of d3 doing nothing and I
played f5 not because I want to play f5
what I do I want to move my king up and
it's hard to move your king up here game
and I want the game to be asymmetrical I
want stuff to happen so he has to think
he played g3 in this position I was
surprised that look this with an engine
and not a 1994 engine that I might have
beaten it the engine today pretty smart
it says man the king on h1 is bad so
what does it play here Matt Larsen would
know that's a hint you guys know Matt
Larsen what you guys do all day gonna
work
well you guys were here all day playing
outside you must have heat stroke yeah
the highest rated player got it right
shocking what do you say g4 yeah
because after g4 you can play kingi - ok
and also after g4 if I play f5 and we
trade all the pawns off the board that's
hard to win ok but even mind if I played
f5 and he didn't mind if his King was on
h1 so we obliged each other they played
g3 because he wants to play King g2 now
g4 loses upon takes tanks tanks tanks
and now the obvious move and the obvious
move and you should always do this in
chess if you can don't let your opponent
do what he wants to do so if you want to
go to the bathroom hold him down wait
you with the right answer right shear
off style but 20 years before except my
bishops not hanging did I get that now
one of you who's he playing ah I think I
know the answer
yeah I do know the answer you know
Claudia no I believe it was top a lob
yeah I think so this should h3x clam
okay now this King's really good okay
especially a bughouse I don't have a
hundred beats on one here no way yeah I
do 700 now like 20
okay so his King can't move but mine can
hooray for me that's why play Bishop
before before this position happened and
the computer says white sign this
computer defends perfect and you have to
realize something that's hard for you to
realize a lot of really blame you not
professional chess players for the most
part when the computer says all zeroes
its equal that doesn't mean it's equal
that means if two supercomputers are
playing each other and they both play
perfect it's a draw but it means like
here if black plays badly it'll be a
draw if white plays deadly you'll see
what happens and badly is easy to do
when you can't move anything then you're
like what do i do do i play a four do i
chill do I play Bishop e2 Bishop f3
Bishop g2 get my king out do I just do
nothing and black can't break through if
you're super computer you look 30 moves
ahead you do the right thing and if I'm
black I can do whatever I want and draw
I have zero percent losing chance so any
Grand Minister wants black here and the
super computers like I could draw this
yeah good luck so you played Bishop d2 I
played this should be sick so he can't
activate his bishop on a fire and with
my king up and he traded pawns my pawns
hanging so I defended it you could write
that down if you're taking notes this
should be five I think was a really bad
move that right no I think it's okay
okay g5 this should be three Bishop g4
what's the threat checkmate the truth
hurts there should have three mate now I
have another threat which isn't much of
a threat but it's a threat I would like
to win you're a pawn because as this
lecture has proven when you Queen you're
a pawn you win right so they should have
three is more important it's me so he
played King g2 and I threatened his pawn
okay now he needs a losing move during
the game I thought I was completely
winning here that feels like nah what
like fine okay but he made it was eight
is illusion after that the computer says
that to Bishop b5 White's fine
and during the game I was like well I
play g4 and then I played Isham f2
recheck and take this pawn okay and I
assume that's what my opponents side so
and I don't know why that's wrong looks
good to me okay if it because like now I
whites fine but he doesn't like that I
don't blame him
so he muddied the waters finally and we
got a really complicated position and he
was worse so then the game was pretty
easy at that point he played me five and
the idea is obvious he's going to take
this and he's going to trade pawns and
so forth naturally if it's somehow he
can take all of my pawns and sacrifice a
bishop it would be two bishops against
one Bishop you don't win that two
bishops they'll beat a bishop to vicious
could be tonight they usually do they
almost always do it practically they
always would maybe a super computer
could defend reasonably well but two
bishops never beat a bishop so II five
is very practical because if I would
upon and he trades all the funds I won't
win so he's trying to trade all the
plans
so I played Bishop III which I thought
was super precise but the computer
prefers Bishop a4 stupid computer and he
took and I took and he got it a check
and I checked him again and I took and
he played Bishop c2 because he didn't
want to lose his a pawn I agree so he
takes my e pawn I'll attack his pawn and
take it and he thought that pawn was
important I don't really blame him and I
played Bishop c7 and I'll upon a head
and I have a past climb and we can sit
here to argue for an hour because I get
paid by the hour say let's vote
I'm guessing 50/50 there's an odd number
I still get 5050 okay and then we'll
have Mike Pence make the time are both
of those plums tests or just the e5 one
and they're free to answer men's Simon
your important what do you think he's
like odds I dunno I was taught as a
child if a pawn can't be stopped by
enough
upon its past and they met your opponent
here you could argue that your pawn
stops your pawn
okay so I would say it to pass plunge
down okay and since I'm playing it I
have to pass points if I was white I
would say one yeah I'm kidding
am I kidding okay so I have at least one
passed pawn and my opponent's king is
very suspicious he's not active in the
center he's not active anywhere and his
King is defending both of these bonds so
if he starts moving his King around he's
gonna lose warp on but keeping your King
on h3 the whole game isn't the best okay
King g3 walking into check King F to my
be pawns hanging I took the Jeep on and
I play Bishop d7 because I want to take
the a pawn and he defended it and I play
g4 some of you are confused why aren't I
taking this pawn you know why yeah
because this point yeah right yeah that
was important so I fixed his pawn so I
can't move but it only can't move with
you know the on passant rule if you
don't know what you can move so if you
play h4 I could take it the computer
will actually let me it's amazing
computer smart although it could be
Bishop h2 is stronger okay but I would
take it okay so I'm officially fixing
his pawn on a bad square and I'm fixing
a hole where the rain gets in like I say
they're not consumed there you could
delete okay so
kingi to defending his pawn bishop check
his kings just great and King e6 so I'm
up a pawn my pawn is further advanced
than his pawn this is a passed pawn and
my Kings better than his so I got a lot
of advantages the disadvantage is if he
sacrifices a bishop for my pawns I don't
win the fewer funds you have you gotta
watch it and you have to think about
that if you're like well he won't take a
pawn I would appease if you any pawns
left then that's exactly what they'll do
but I have enough funds okay Bishop 1
King b5 amazing I'm moving my king up
defended my pawn Mike hang up
and the truth hurts and as kind knock
would say I have a king and you don't ok
and now I have a plan everybody can
understand yeah good plan
ok and he understood it well so what did
he do yeah you designed but I like the
end of this game it reminds me of the
venue akin that I lecture on a lot will
get my king and look at his king he did
move his king a lot like my first
opponent Fisher but he kept it like on
his side of the board sorted in the
corner and I move my king up the board
ok and obviously there were reasons why
that happened but you always want to
move your king of the Borg then you have
a king if your opponent makes you I
didn't tell you nothing leave me alone
it wasn't my fault ok it's funny I was
playing
Judit Polgar in 1988 or 89 I'll never
know I think was 88 I'm not sure
actually think of thinking right now it
was in Belgium where I was living and
she was done I was 13 she was better
than me and we played a game 15 and she
fled the Kings gambit and there's no
score of this game was 15-minute we can
keep score and she was better the whole
game and we got to a double rook ending
and she moved her King off because you
move your king off in the end game and
then i mated her she missed making one
so I played Nate and there was a huge
crowd you think they're rooting for me
or her I'll give you a hit it wasn't me
so when I needed her event they all
walked away grumbling and their period
right and she was like how can you get
naked sometimes so when you walk the
King off the board you might get mated
but but not here because my phone has no
pieces yeah but usually in an end game
walking your King ups a good idea if
your point has Queens and rooks idea I
didn't say nothing but when there's just
minor pieces on the board if I'm up a
king that I'm doing well so that was a
really boring position and I had some
minor advantages that super computers
don't care about but when you're playing
a human if make it let your King get
active if they get their pawns attack if
their king is trapped it's hard to play
and my King was never checked I just
walked up the board and he was trying to
figure out what to do and eventually he
cracked according to the engine he could
have defended that error but when you
lose you could always
better right Bensimon like Ben's family
could feel better but he doesn't he's
like call me of can I take the day off
now I never that's true you know the
last time he filmed he doesn't know
either
it's been two weeks are you guys shocked
in the truth hurts yeah this is all this
is all getting edited yeah that's good
that's good point any questions okay so
- what's the word - finish that's not
the word Mystics English in here not you
not you yeah it's a concluded who said
that you Wow
you showed up late good job to conclude
in the endgame move your king up push
your passed pawns get past pawns
okay you don't have to ask pawns you
ain't gonna win there's no Queen are you
I got me with a bishop I mean I could
but that's going to be hard get to put
his king here I put my king here and
then me I don't think that's going to
happen is it so if you have minor pieces
you're not going to meet your opponent
but you can make a queen then you can
make your opponent so you need passed
pawn to the ending you need an active
King and then you could win if the
opening don't move your king of the
board once you're playing me okay okay
all right and then my favorite
conclusion you guys can do it and what a
quiet
yeah class is dismissed even though they
did it
[Music]